[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
for most americans who don't live in new
york city new york is a lot like your
half drunk
nerdy well uncle flashy loud always
bragging about himself though somewhat
less impressive than he claims to be
you love your uncle you just don't want
to know too much about his personal life
there's no question it is messy
and weird you suspect he owes a lot of
people money you know he eats with his
mouth open
still he's your uncle your lives are
intertwined if you get some incurable
disease
and dies you'll be sad about it and new
york is the same way
even if you dislike new york too much to
visit
you should care what happens there
because you're an american and new york
is by far this country's biggest city
new york has more than twice as many
people as second place los angeles it's
physically tiny
the entire island of manhattan is
smaller than dallas fort worth airport
but new york produces close to 10
percent of our total
gdp in this country so what happens to
new york
matters to the rest of us like the place
or not
until recently new york seemed to be
thriving officials there had succeeded
in doing the
single most important thing that civic
leaders anywhere can do
they made their city safe for normal
people to
live there new york was one of the least
dangerous metro areas in the world they
bragged about it
there's no mystery how they did it the
city hired tens of thousands
of cops they threw criminals and
anti-social destroyers
in jail and they left them there and it
worked new york improved
dramatically people with choices people
could live anywhere
wanted to live there and then in a short
space of time mayor bill de blasio
arrived
and he set about reversing the formula
on the basis of no
evidence de blasio attacked the police
department of new york as racist
he then cut a billion dollars from the
nypd budget
demoralized cops stopped making arrests
and almost immediately crime and
violence in the city exploded
in a single manhattan neighborhood the
upper east side robberies have jumped by
286 percent this year things fell apart
new yorkers who could leave the city did
leave the entire tax base fleeing to
florida
bill de blasio watched these entirely
predictable things happen
glassy-eyed breathing through his mouth
probably too high to process
it all in the end de blasio concluded
that none of it
was his fault new yorkers he decided
have had it too
easy what they need is more suffering so
today
de blasio announced that he plans to
encircle the entire city
with military-style checkpoints not to
stop violent criminals
but prevent people from visiting from
other places
there was no public discussion of this
ahead of time there was no debate
de blasio just decreed it so starting
today we're going to do something
new in new york city we will have
checkpoints at key
entry points to the city travelers
coming in from those states
will be given information about the
quarantine they will be reminded that it
is required not optional they'll be
reminded that
failure to quarantine is a violation of
state law and it comes with serious
penalties fact under certain
circumstances the fines can be as high
as
ten thousand dollars got that
it doesn't make any sense at all he
didn't bother to explain why they're
doing it there's no science behind it
but the one thing that you know for sure
is
it's your fault not his yours
your failures are a severe violation of
the law
says bill de blasio you'll be punished
if you disobey you are
bad so travel to new york city are about
to learn a very important lesson it's a
lesson that residents of nursing homes
in new york the ones who survived have
already learned
and it's this the people who make the
worst decisions the decisions that kill
people
never face consequences for those
decisions only you do
so shut up and show us your papers
peasant now one of the many ironies here
and there are many
is that back in march of this year new
york threatened to sue the state of
rhode island
for trying to set up the very same kind
of checkpoints
at the time andrew cuomo he's the
governor of new york called checkpoints
like this quote
unconstitutional and reactionary
so what changed well who knows don't
waste your time looking for consistency
bureaucracies don't have to be
consistent because they're in charge
they can do whatever they want they
don't have to explain why
so at the very moment that they've
decided to treat taxpayers of new york
like refugees in a war zone
with checkpoints leaders in new york
seem to doing all they can to make life
easier for thugs with guns back in may
for example the city of new york
released a gang member from custody
without bail
he'd been charged with attempted murder
but they just let him go
here are pictures of the alleged crime
imagine letting
that guy the guy with the gun shooting
someone on the sidewalk just
walk out free why would you do that you
would have to hate the people who live
in your city
in order to do that prosecutors say that
that suspect a man called darius sutton
went on after new york let him out to
commit three more shootings because of
course he did
bill de blasio doesn't want to talk
about any of that he doesn't want you to
talk about it either
the thing about social justice is you're
just gonna have to ignore the details
instead city officials would like you to
stay terrified of the chronovirus
because
more anxiety about invisible viruses
will take your mind off the shootings
and the decay
so in a few days new york will begin
following and harassing
travelers they're going to text and call
you if you plan to travel if you don't
respond
city workers may come to your home in
person listen to a man
called ted long explain the plan he runs
something called the
test and trace core in new york tomorrow
we're going to be deploying teams to
penn station to stop
travelers to ensure that they've
completed the travel form we've made
more than 86 000 phone calls to
travelers coming into new york city from
the designated high risk states
and we've sent more than 20 000 text
messages to date
and if we can't get through to you on
the phone we've deployed teams that are
now
knocking on your door to check in with
you
oh so ted long is going to deploy teams
to penn station have you been to penn
station recently
it's a homeless shelter the whole thing
oh there's a guy with his trousers down
relieving himself in the corner hey
they're dealing crack right there oh
they're smoking it over here
go to penn station and ask yourself is
this real is this america
but ted long is going to deploy teams to
hassle people who are traveling
to new york to help the city stay afloat
right keep in mind the vehement little
lecture you just heard about public
health
comes from the same people who forced
coronavirus patients
into nursing homes and killed many by
doing it
these are the same leaders who gave
violent rioters control of the city
streets
but suddenly they are very concerned
about your health
right what they're actually concerned
about as always
is maintaining political control and of
course money money is suddenly
a pressing concern for them and the main
problem is and
they're going to fix this if they can
that under our current system it's
pretty difficult to
force people to remain in crumbling
cities because
for now we still have freedom of
movement rich people are running away
from new york they have more freedom of
movement than anyone because they can
afford to go wherever they want
and they see what's coming it's pretty
obvious they plan to be somewhere else
when it arrives and this raises the
question of who is going to pay
for all these failed and poisonous
social experiments the ones that turned
a train station into a homeless shelter
in midtown
andrew cuomo is smart enough to be
worried about this he is now
begging millionaires to come back to the
hellhole he helped create
we used to be worried millionaires tax
people might leave
no no no the burden shifted we're trying
to get people to come back
i literally talk to people all day long
who are now in the hamptons house
who also lived here or in their hudson
valley house
or in their connecticut weekend house
and i say you got to come back when are
you coming back
we'll go to dinner i'll buy you a drink
come over i'll cook they're not coming
back right now
it's pathetic it's pathetic oh they're
in their hampton's house come back to
new york it's great i'll meet you at
penn station we'll get a burger and some
hepatitis
yeah so it turns out rich people may be
evil
but in the end you need a few of them to
pay for everything otherwise you have no
political power
that's an obvious truth that cuomo is in
effect saying
the city's pothead mayor by contrast
cannot admit that out loud it's entirely
possible he doesn't even understand the
principle
but bill de blasio does know that his
disintegrating city
will need money from somewhere and soon
so he's thinking that the rest of
america should pay for his disaster
if we do not get federal support soon
i'm very worried about these stimulus
talks in washington wealth because i
seem to be going nowhere fast
my challenge is where am i going to have
the people to do this work
i may have to do as many as layoffs of
22
000 city employees from every department
by october 1st if i don't get federal
help
so consult your bill de blasio cheat
sheet look it up we keep ours right here
and if you do you will see that it was
less than a month ago that this same man
bill de blasio threatened to
sue the federal government if they
helped too much
if they deployed federal law enforcement
officers to his city
now he's wanting that the feds are not
doing enough
shameless obviously of course it is and
yet to be fair it's possible that de
blasio has no short-term memory left
and simply doesn't remember what he said
last month